it's time for screen junkies boobie
bytes what's up party people
oh hello hi what's up party people over
there welcome to movie fights in case
you haven't noticed by now I am NOT Hal
Rudnick I'm Spencer J Gilbert haleh's on
his honeymoon give him a celebratory
hoot-hoot on his social media you stuck
with me and and these fellas because
today it's the fourth phase phase four
of the month-long almost got him dan
Merle Invitational so close I promise I
won't hold it against you as a man who
almost got him but everyone here will be
trying to score a win over the movie
fights champ culminating in next week's
fourth of July last fighter standing or
the belts but the belt double be on the
line next week nice no well I'm bringing
with you the belt no like it's real
until the belts on the line okay fair
enough fair enough but we do have your
toughest challenge yet I want to think
first step he's one half of the real
rejects keeper of the bathroom keys is
that an inside joke I missed it's great
well you were gone I'm excited to be
here I've never been in a video with you
Spencer nice he's very excited every
fight dan has had in the last few weeks
and I've learned nothing on how to beat
him I'm very excited to be here
there goes the world's worst fanpage
they think me and cucumber the same
second up Keys Coast of the nerd goat
podcast you can see Monday and
Wednesdays honest to you it's edgren hey
guys it's really awesome to be here the
Greg was saying earlier before err that
this was like a dream it really is it
really it's like one those are you wake
up you're naked in high school you got a
test that's what it feels like to be
right now there's different
interpretations I'm definitely in a
nightmare cuz it's just me as just a
frail guy rushes to old Tron's and I'm
just I'm just trying to stay in it baby
well it's hablas Joe start acting props
to you for setting reasonably achievable
dreams you guys and then the man of the
hour
he's the reigning movie fights champ yes
and I was excited for this i when we
were planning all the different ones I
was like I want to definitely fight two
guys who I was in a championship fight
with mm-hmm because I love that caliber
competition so I'm very much looking
forward to this one awesome and but
that's not all there's more people in
this small room over there
it's London Calling LAN eros and the
voice of the people Daniel retro is back
what happened Spencer was white you were
gone the bathroom here was under
construction and we had to go upstairs
and we had a spy night number of keys
and Greg walked off with one of our
precious few yes bathroom please
intentionally yeah brutal that's what
the champs need to do to get an edge for
those of you who haven't seen movie
fights before hello
it's best-of-seven points game there are
three three main rounds I believe longer
rounds and then a bunch of speed rounds
to see who can get to four first in the
event of some ties we'll do some some
tie breakers and come on you guys know
how this works by now let's just fight
okay drop that package
[Music]
[Laughter]
you guys
spider-man ffh opens next week who gives
the best performance in any spider-man
movie Gregg we'll start with you yeah my
pick for this one for all these picks
today I'm experimenting by just going
with my personal favorites I don't know
if that ultimately be the best but I
actually have a lot of faith that this
one is the best one of them all I went
with Tobey Maguire from spider-man 2 in
that film Peter Parker he is struggling
with balancing his personal life and
bouncing his superhero life and what I
love about this performance here is yes
it's funny it's endearing its earnest at
the same time though it's very relatable
I find it to be the most authentic
performance out of any performance in
any of the spider-man films in general
because we can all relate with the idea
of having a balance you know like having
a work life and then having a social
life and within this film what I love
about Tobey Maguire's portrayal is that
he is always he's multi-layered in every
single scene there's always an inner
conflict and he gets a chance to shine
and show a variety of different emotions
and a whole range of range of his
character by the specific relationships
he has with people like with Aunt May
there's always this resonation of guilt
underneath it for what happened with
Uncle Ben and she doesn't know the truth
with you know like Harry Osborn and even
Jay jonah Jameson the situation you
can't control so he has this built-up
angst and then with Mary Jane Watson you
see this side of him that's like boyish
romantic and sweet
I think his performance here it gives
the most range he leads this film he
anchors it and on top of that too is
very generous actor to the point where
he consistently brings out the best in
other performers in every scene that
he's in so I loved him in it and he's
also a total badass to do in the film so
yeah I def
we have to go with Tobey Maguire in
spider-man 2 alright strong opening
salvo Edie who do you got well I picked
it's it's pretty conviction of the
conventional pick it's spider-man played
by Tom Holland and I really do believe
that there's a qualitative difference
between this spider-man and in the other
and it isn't beholden to any other films
much like some of the performances from
my distinguished competition
I this one is it's him establishing that
he's gonna be spider-man for 10 to 15
years and he's laying that groundwork so
solidly that you can see that at the end
of that movie he's doing so many
different acting challenges from doing
an accent I'm not trying to downplay
that but doing a really awesome English
accent I mean a regular American English
accent that slips maybe one time the
whole movie when he gets really excited
there's also the level of him being like
obviously he doesn't have all the scenes
to cry over bunka bin but you feel the
gravitas of those moments when they talk
around those in this film and I think
this is this is one of the first this is
the first spider-man movie in this whole
conversation we're about to have that
actually does establish a whole new
continuity and that is on the back of
Tom Holland and he really does play the
perfect balance between like tortured
soul and you know the Pagliacci that
lasted to keep him crying hmm
awesome ed Tommy Holland Dan I went on a
limb and picked Anne on spider-man it's
actually my favorite not just my
favorite villain but I think still maybe
my favorite character from any of the
spider-man movies which is Alfred Molina
as Doctor Octopus Doc Ock in spider-man
2 I think that he really ushered in an
era of a prestige actor who wasn't
afraid to bring pathos and gravitas to
this kind of role and why I think that
it puts it above any other performance
in a spider-man movie is is the depth of
what he's asked to do this is maybe by
appearance perhaps the most ridiculous
spider-man villain he's got Big Mac
panic alarms coming out of his back he's
a he's in a in this movie he's like a
middle-aged guy in a kind of a girdle he
could have looked really ridiculous
really stupid and Sam Raimi's style the
way that that he plays the movies the
villains have to go sometimes and and
you see that in the the birth of Doc Ock
sequence almost to these operatic
heights of just no and I mean if it's
done wrong it can be really bad Alfred
Molina is able to do that to do I am a
guy with mechanical arms climbing up the
side of a bank and balance that with the
smaller more measured a character that
he is at the beginning of the movie
where he's Peters mentor and his friend
and then is able to play the entire
movie basically opposite himself and do
it and make it a villain that you can
relate to a villain that you still fear
the amount of different things that
Alfred Molina was asked to do in that
movie to juggle the tones the fact that
he did it so well and was still able to
play that the role both as big as it
needed to be and as small as it needed
to be makes it my favorite performance
in any of the spider-man movies and why
I picked them today all right well
that's gonna be tough to tear each other
down but let's hear it well I mean III
would certainly say that these movies do
kind of poach great actors for different
roles I mean Jonathan Rhys Davies who's
not an Oscar winner I don't believe but
I he was the kingpin in the 80s in a
freaking TV movie and then he got Willem
Dafoe in the very first movie Willem
Dafoe is an oscar-worthy actor at the
very least so I think that point is a
little off I also think that the
operatic nature that you're speaking of
is to its detriment
whereas I just got to say Tom Hollands
performance is very naturalistic even
amongst these three I feel like Tom
Holland is he's charismatic he's very
likable but I feel like this idea of so
much tortured soul and gravitas I don't
actually feel like that's present in the
film it to me it's a very light-hearted
film and his performance is very
light-hearted he's probably the funniest
spider-man and probably the funniest
character to have appeared in any of
this the spider-man franchise it's
definitely the most spider-man
spider-man 2 thank you I don't think he
is the most spider-man
the fact that he doesn't have this level
of like I know we are kind of sick with
the quote with great power comes great
responsibility at the same time that's
so integral to who spider-man is it's
like what's his relatability exactly I
feel like Tobey Maguire's is much more
relatable I mean like Thomas let's half
the movie hat not having power so
where's all the angst between him having
a conception of the movie ban was like
two and a half hours or something like
that
yeah that's part of the beauty of his
performance in it is that you're
watching the guy who's having to learn
about what sacrifices should he take
when he's going down this path of you
know trying to be a superhero and he's
drawn to his personal life he decides to
sacrifices the superhero stuff but then
he's in his personal life you see this
very subtle contained performance where
like he'll see people being harmed in
danger or someone that even gets killed
and just by his expressions alone you
can feel this overbearing guilt because
I love how contained it is because he
has literally no one to open up to Ellie
everyone retort to that and it's just
that he does have a whole other movies
worth of adventures a whole other movie
has the main character the worth of
adventures to draw upon to build a
separate layer to this performance that
you're describing and this this sort of
a very different journey that he's in
within and within spider-man - as
compared to spider-man one I mean my guy
is establishing a new interpretation for
the next like I said 15 years and and
he's also doing all the work of like
what that particular version of
spider-man is making him do he must show
this hero worship towards Tony Stark
which wasn't there frankly in the
comments about ten years ago that's my
issue he's got to do a lot of understand
he's got to do a lot just he's doing all
of this world building all this
necessary storytelling in a very
naturalistic and confident way debating
over who's playing spider-man better and
that for me is why I actually sort of
disqualified anyone playing spider-man
when I'm looking at this is that I think
it's it is a little bit it's like Spider
Man is always Spider Man this idea of
like I'm wrestle in your video with
togood wire I'm wrestling with the
responsibilities of my personal life of
my superhero life that's in the first
movie that's in the third spider-man
movie that's in both age of Garfield
movies that's in your movie that is just
a quality about spider-man I don't think
it's the performance that makes that
relatable I think it's because that is
an essential part of that character
spider-man is written to be relatable to
a comic-book audience because he
the lead character of that comic book
he's aimed toward the kids I don't think
that's as silly because Tobey Maguire's
performance was great
I think that's just the quality of the
character same with Tom Holland I think
he's likable and I think he's fine
because that's the way the characters
written whereas with Doc Ock I think if
you look at what the comic book
character is and then what Alfred Molina
did you know the comic book character is
a guy in the green bodysuit with orange
underwear on who's cackling with his big
blast is going up and what Alfred Molina
does is he takes that and he grounds it
in a reality that makes you buy that
he's the guy cackling up on the building
but that he is also somebody who's Peter
Parker's equal and somebody who you you
yourself are conflicted about you feel
bad for him you're not it's not just
some arch villain you feel bad for him
because you know the struggle the
internal conflict that this guy is
feeling and Alfred Molina is the reason
why you feel that he brings that to that
performance I mean what I would say to
counter that though is I feel like the
set up of Alf Ramon we watch spider-man
2 a few weeks ago and I feel like the
set up of Alfred Molina has Doc Ock is
great it's very nuanced it's very
layered and then there's a scene where
he awakens and he's talking to his
tentacles by himself and he even there
he's conflicted and then for most of the
movie until after that point for most of
the movie when you check in with Doc Ock
all that nuances kind of stripped away
it's just him pretty much being out for
Molina the bad guy he's you know he kids
us you and me on top of the building the
train sequence where he talks to Harry
Osborn and then he kidnaps MJ and then
he has another showdown with spider-man
and it isn't until it's like last five
minutes where that nuance finally comes
back need some scenery chewed he's there
for you if you you know he is for most
of that movie and and to say that that
is better than the naturalistic
performance of Tom I'm Tom Holland doing
all the stuff that I was stating earlier
in regards to setting up a new
expectation for what this characters
gonna be for years also doing a lot of
storytelling also this thing that he's
just a light hearted guy through all
that I obviously you guys didn't see the
scene where he was like buried and going
to die on his own and let down his Aunt
May let down his Uncle Ben let down Tony
let down all the Avengers that's a he
had he had more at stake in that moment
that any of these characters have had in
any of these movies was seamless except
the scene where
a bird under the machinery in the he's
gonna let everybody down the classic
Steve Ditko you know beautiful
illustrated scene and they did that
actual justice in a movie and it was
because he is a good actor a bad actor
in that scene a bad actor in most of
this movie would really fall flat
classic Steve Ditko thing that that's a
Spider Man moment don't make this your
friend about both of these things like
the things that you're harping on that
makes this character relatable because
of the performance I would argue are
actually because it's Spider Man of
course you're gonna relate to them and
root for him of course you're gonna find
that to be a heroic moment he's the main
character in the movie he's the guy that
you're already rooting for a lot of the
work is already done and I'm not saying
that these guys were bad in their
performances but I think that when you
look at a bet at the best performance
you look at something that takes a
character from the comics and adds
something to it I disagree with the
assertion that the nuance is stripped
out of Alfred Molina Scott the scene
again played against himself against a
cartoon arm which it could look totally
stupid
that scene is him basically convincing
himself committing to this line of I'm
going to be a super villain yes from
then on he is carrying out this task
that's the part of the role that does
require him to be the villain but as you
come around full circle the fact that at
the end of the movie you come back to
the fact that he realizes what have I
done like this this part of himself
that's been buried and suppressed
awakens and he realizes the error of
what he's doing you need to go to those
extremes to have that moment at the end
I think what sets Alfred Molina apart is
he's not just playing spider-man well
because these are spider-man themes that
are hit upon him on several movies he's
taking a villain that on the page is
just a very arch villain and he's
bringing his strengths as an actor to a
role to add depth to flesh it out to
make you sympathize with him to make him
more than what he is it's not just
writing on the spider-man themes it's
actually building a great performance
that varies between huge and very small
the modulation is great the fact is able
to pull it off is great I still think he
stands as the best villain in the
spider-man movie I think that's why
spider-man 2 is regarded largely as one
of the better spider-man movies if not
the best one it's not just because Tobey
Maguire's in it it's because he has a
great villain to play off of and that's
melina I think he's the best performance
in any of the spider-man films well this
is my thing
discounting the main character and your
appreciation for the greatest
performance of spider-man movie is like
discounting Beyonce's contribution to
your Destiny's Child essay I don't
understand how you can do that it
doesn't seem to make any sense it's
certainly very hipster to pick the oh
yeah I like their drummer the best oh
that's great Dan it is to my mind quite
a bit easier to do the first human
version of this character ever seen on
celluloid than to reinterpret this
character for an entire new generation I
would argue that one as a greater acting
task and one is pulled off in this movie
quite well and does its dupe to operatic
histrionics for for a half of the
performance at least and I just believe
that without those stunts Tom Holland is
able to deliver a great powerful
concrete setting the foundation for the
next 10 years of Marvel movies
performance and that must be lauded at
some point you must give the lead singer
their due at some point you must give
the best interpretation of spider-man
they're due if we're talking about the
best spider-man performance in a
spider-man freakin movie all right Greg
nice final argument there red
[Laughter]
okay well when I was talking about with
with that moment with the tentacle scene
that's his first scene what a doc ock
where he there is that nuance and that
inner conflict that you're talking about
what I was referring to is that from
there on out until Tobey Maguire
actually destroys whatever is in the
back of his neck
and he's able to come down to himself
then we finally get that nuance back but
for most of that movie he's actually
just writing this line of evil dude he's
just yeah even when he checked in them
by himself at one point he's just being
an evil guy and to me that shift kind of
feels a little left field because all
that conflict is kind of stripped away
and I also think that some of those
moments now when he's talking to the to
himself essentially like I give him a
lot of credit for having pretty much
worth of green screen in that moment and
that's in some of those scenes it just
feels a little cheesy as of today and
with Tom Holland I mean you keep saying
he's like powerful and everything but I
don't really feel that gravitas when I
watched spider-man homecoming or even in
Civil War like he's what I think they
did with him and there's they really
amped up his personality they really
amped up the funny but there's a lot of
depth that I just don't feel present
here with Tobey Maguire and spider-man
to you that's like it's it's easy to
write off that it's just the writing of
the character but you need a good actor
you need a great actor if you're gonna
be in the lead to not only honor the
writing but also elevate it and for me
Tobey Maguire does that out of any of
these performances he has the one scene
and that actually makes me cry when he
like confesses to Aunt May the truth of
what happened to Uncle Ben and he's like
he's trying to get his personal life in
order he thinks he's thought being
spider-man but in that moment when he
starts to tear up I start to tear up
that overwhelming guilt that he's
feeling and every single scene he has an
inner conflict with whomever he's
interacting with and I think you get the
most variety the most shades of a human
being within his performance like the
way he just looks at Mary Jane I want to
talk about really quickly I'll wrap this
up soon the way he until he just looks
at people when they're talking the part
of acting they say is reacting and
listening and Tobey Maguire has the best
skills when it
comes to that there's this whole moment
where a maze giving this whole speech
about being a hero or when Mary Jane's
talking to him and the camera will just
slowly pan in on him and you connect
with him you feel him you relate with
him and while I think Doc Ock is the
best spider-man villain we've had I
don't think it's the overall best
performance you just didn't know though
I'll actually have enough scenes to
truly demonstrate that and I also feel
like Tobey Maguire still brings a lot of
snarkiness when he's in the suit he
still brings a lot of that humor to the
character it's to make that character
that relatable and to be that moving and
even the moment where Mary Jane gets
kidnapped by Doc Ock and you feel the
rage within him every time you watch
that movie you're like go kick his ass
man like you just feel it dude so yeah I
feel like he has the most moving
emotionally effective powerful
performance of anyone in the franchise
all right time Wow
as a barnburner I believe the way this
works is now I have to kick it over for
a long time a forgot my facts from some
facts sure Alfred Molina born in 1953
spider-man 2 released in 2004 she's
about 50 years old definitely counts as
being middle-aged I would say a lot of
people did pick up on this in the chat
room I could not find an image of Doc
Ock with orange Underpants there's a lot
he's in a green body suit he's either
got a yellow belt and boots or an orange
belt and boots but not
Michelle Williams Kelly Rowland very
talented lady many wonderful drummers we
don't we don't want to sass any of these
wonderful drummers don't forget the
funky drummer yes amen to that
lose your facts you are the voice of the
people have they voted tonight did I
forget to mention people should be
voting on their picks so normally we'll
go back and we'll do yours cuz I don't
want to say the answer to the poll don't
say case it doesn't wind up counting but
yeah see you guys you can get in you
have like two seconds to go ahead and
get in the last vote we've been telling
you guys how to do it on the chat so
it's fine great okay so in my reckoning
and no whispering also you're out
you're really arguing for the gravitas
of one scene and I feel like the rest of
your arguments were really predicated on
things that the movie was doing and not
necessarily the performance of the way
that it was establishing continuity and
laying the groundwork for 10 to 15 years
of spider-man hmm that's more the job of
spider-man homecoming rather than Tom
Holland so it came down to a to Dan and
Greg man this was tough because I feel
like you both did really zero in on the
on the performance I mean Dan you
knocked him with the same criticism
there was more function of the movie
than it was Tobey Maguire but I think
you countered back really well with the
way he's such a supportive scene partner
and his looks and reaction shots and the
way you hit Dan back on that you lose
the nuance halfway through the movie I
wish I had a fact check on this because
I don't know how much of the film Alfred
Molina spends in that arch-villain mode
versus his nuanced scenes I wish I could
go back and tally it up and see if that
criticism really holds or having a chart
for that you were both really great on
this and Beau Sierra didn't on the
performance that said I'm giving this
one to Greg congratulations thanks
Spencer all right never mind
like this sort of worked out its kind of
unfortunately how the topic sort of
worked out for them but I felt like
Gregg and it kind of took each other out
by both picking spider-man's I think
they both made a case for their
spider-man being a good naturalistic
take and I think they both hit Dan on
Alfred Molina as being a more operatic
sort of a more over-the-top kind of take
but I don't think they won me over in
convincing me that that's worse than
what they were proposing I sort of agree
that Alfred Molina is doing something
bigger and different but I like that I
think Danny made a really good case for
whether it's so effective in the movie
so I'm going with that should just have
Spencer 45 percent of the vote we have
Alfred Molina and spider-man 2 34
percent for Tom Holland and homecoming
20% for Tobey Maguire and spider-man was
only around I'm confident about
[Applause]
everyone wants to know why no one picked
JK's of it yeah there was a lot it's a
great what five minutes total maybe I
really believe that he wants pictures of
spider-man again why people should not
have a voice in honor midsummer what is
the best horror film of the 21st century
dun dun dun
alright guys a lot of horror movies been
made since then I believe now we'll
start with Edie what's your if I'm gonna
call something the greatest horror movie
of the 21st century so far that like
means a lot it means a movie that can be
called scary and it also qualifies as
like a game-changing movie
it's a Twitter calling a 21st century
seems to intone like a new approach to
horror and it's subgenres and to me that
movie's 28 days later
I think that movie is a real deal
game-changer from its use of video to
create sort of an immediacy and our
realism to all this horrific action to
the fact that it did bring back the
zombie genre I think that this and
walking dead or in some sort of race as
to how to revive it and also I think it
transcends the zombie genre is really
about contagion and it has a lot to say
about civility in the social contract
and and how tenuous that is and it has
it's smart it's a new movie for a new
millennium and it has a lot to say and
it changed the game so if that those are
my criteria and that's why I'm arguing
20 days later all right cool Dan
hereditary whoops I just rendered answer
[Music]
incoming I would be I didn't thought
about showing these more of a comedy
it's hard for me to make the case fell
love shot is dead but yeah I would be I
would be lying to everyone and everyone
would call me out if I said anything
else but hereditary I know it came out
last year that's how strongly I feel
about this movie I know that perspective
is important but when I look at the
horror genre and I look at this film and
it's it's it's it's what does this movie
bring to the table that I can say if you
are a horror fan that you're gonna that
you're gonna love about this movie it is
the it is the existential terror the
relatable terror of loss the the really
relatable thing and this is one of my
favorite genres a part of people
thinking you're crazy when you're not
crazy and trying to convince people that
this is actually happening and no one
will believe you
if it was just those two things that
would be like a real potboiler kind of a
thing but add on top of that the fact
that you have the crazy cult stuff this
idea of a group that's out to get you
the ritual sacrifice if you're a gore
hound the that is there that is present
you have the supernatural element that
comes in it has legitimately a couple of
the scariest moments in a movie but the
one in particular with Toni Collette in
the bedroom if you haven't seen the
movie I'll just say light in the bedroom
is one of the scariest moments one of
the scariest images I've seen in a
horror movie that I can think of this
century when you look at the genre I
think that it's so varied and there's so
many different ways to play it I mean
there's lots of different kinds of heart
even as I because my mind first went to
hereditary and I looked at all the other
different possibilities that I could go
with and each one I played I'm like well
it brings this to the table but what is
it what else does it have and as far as
just like pointing to the genre from a
performance level from a craft level
from a filmmaking level from a level of
just sheer breadth of what is there and
different ways to scare you hereditary
is the one that stands above to me and
then that's why it's my choice all right
great
what's your pick
okay so yeah when my favorite which is
an odd one
it's Sam Raimi's drag me to hell I adore
this movie so much I saw it twice in the
theaters pretty close to the time it
opened and I just remember being in the
theater and hearing so many people
screaming and laughing simultaneously I
feel like it's such a depth I'm like
okay there be a scene worth like there's
like gross-out gags and then there'd be
a lot of terrifying elements and it's
all just it's weaving all these multiple
tones and I find that to be one of the
best things about what Sam Raimi because
no one could do what Sam Raimi does when
I think about best horror film of the
21st century there's literally no other
film like this one because only Sam
Raimi can pull this kind of film off -
to be able to the idea why I love the
Hornet is because it's it has this great
ability of tension and release I feel
like with a lot of horror movies we kind
of ride this like one tone this one note
and oftentimes that kind of dilutes down
the horror because they're kind of just
in this this realm that you get used to
it after a while we're in this movie you
have no idea when something scary is
gonna happen I know we crap on lads it's
common on the Internet to like you know
crap on like jump scares but when done
right when done effectively when done
with style when it's earned Sam Raimi
does it the absolute best there are
sequences in here that are just flat-out
frightening the the lady in the film the
old leah is it's not PC anymore to say
gypsy right because that's what they
describe her huh probably not the old
European woman I'll say all right the
old European woman is one of the most
terrifying people I've ever seen on
screen it was one of those experiences
that when I would go anywhere at night I
would just imagine her popping up
somewhere I'd be scared to walk alone
places and it also gets this great
leading performance from Alison Lohman
where that sets up this wonderful moral
quandary of does she really deserve to
go to hell because it starts off where
she makes a decision that screws over
the actor the actor's name Lorna raver I
think you could look that up lon
Lorna raver and he screws her over but
then you're like okay that was kind of a
dick move but then as the film
progresses and you're watching I like
her just go crazy killer a cat and you
know Luke pushing away her boyfriend and
just going just batshit insane
throughout the film you start going okay
I know she messed up but does she really
deserve to go to hell for this so I love
the debate I love the characters and I
love the arcs but I also love that it's
just a purely entertaining horror thrill
ride okay fight it out y'all
I was angry the hell is fun it really is
it's fun but it's I think that Sam Raimi
at this one in particular was the CG
okay is it doesn't look very good to me
he was still experimenting with effects
and stuff I think it already looks a
little dated even though it's only about
ten years old well that was part of the
intentional points of some of the
gimmicks was to have that b-movie
throwback to stuff like Evil Dead in
there maybe so but I think either the
study the effects of Evil Dead 2 for
example to me look better than some of
the effects in dragon wood hell because
just I think that sometimes when you use
computers it just doesn't even if that's
the aesthetic you're going for it still
looks dated whereas a practical effect
stuff like that is timeless in a lot of
sin sure I think dragon hills it's kind
of like Evil Dead 2 I think you'll have
to is more fun but it's it's a fun movie
but I mean would I elevate it to the
next session on other than being a Raimi
fan I wouldn't put it above you know a
lot of other movies there's a lot of
other movies that def jump scares the
whole idea of tension and release that's
every horror movie that's the whole
thing is like this idea that you're
building up tension and then at some
point this release is gonna quit to have
a movie with this much energy to have a
movie with this much of a thrill ride
you just don't get that anymore with
horror like I honestly like hereditary
to me is like another kind of babadook
movie it's a film where that was my
second choice
very similar like we're talking about
best from the 21st century and I can't
think of another movie that's like drag
me to hell were like hereditary this
idea like the grieving mother with a
with a strange relationship with her son
and then this a mixture of a mental
illness but there's something
supernatural actually happening
I felt like babadook did that also
really well and pretty fairly recently
to hereditary - hereditary is release as
well and I also feel like hereditary
third act is heavily criticized for a
reason because it a week and it really
undercuts a lot of the film and then it
has this reveal that makes you look back
at the whole moving you kind of have
this like you know Zemo Lex Luthor a
factory like wait a minute how did this
this cult exactly pull all that they
would have to have a lot of very
convenient things in order to take place
in order for this thing to go down I
disagree with that completely I don't
think the third act undercuts anything
about the movie I agree that there are
some people that like the third axle
that don't like the third act but I
don't think that great movies need to
necessarily be universally loved I think
that that's one of the great things
about hereditary is that people can see
it and it does spark debate I think
that's what great films do they're not
just a thrill right or just a scary
movie it's drag me to hell when it's
over you know I saw it and I haven't
thought about it since because it was
fun while I was watching it hereditary I
still think about it I still try to
piece things together and did that work
and how did that happen or I realized
something that I missed the second when
I see it the fourth or fifth time you
think that's what makes it great I don't
want to ignore 28 days later though it
sucks huh
I'm like I'm like a henchman chillin in
the corner waiting to get kicked I agree
that it was definitely something where
it was influential in the sense that
they were using TV and stuff and it did
help - it was an era where there were
several things that were part of the
zombies coming back into mythology but
is it the best I would agree that it's
influential but I don't know if I would
say it's the best I think it just was
its no because of its medium but I don't
know if the content of it really rises
above I would certainly argue though for
this generation is much like Richard
Pryor doing stuff that Def Jam comedians
did later and then people go Richard
Pryor is not funny when you look when
you look at that movie for its time it
was quite innovative because one thing
it did to the whole so-called genre onra
is strip the zombie part away it is that
you can't have that layer of distance
that oh that's not grandma
no that's grandma she's still alive and
she's run out of for 340 with a butcher
knife ready to break you off you know
and that's really happening to you and I
think unfortunately for both of you guys
movies in my personal opinion and I'm
not trying to be snarky but I believe
there are there's something to horror
movies having something you can relate
to and I love the fact that you it's
lost right you're saying that lost
everybody's experience that's why that's
one of the things that you can relate to
in that movie and I certainly understand
that and in your movie it's just like a
one minor transgression with a Romani
person you can get dragged to hell you
know one one minor transgression and I
make a mistake right so is this horrific
but I've maintained that the entirety of
society turning on you is something that
to a person everyone can relate to
whether you have a daughter you can lose
or a family with mental illness things
that you can imprint on or whether you
can you engage with with people you know
it's fortunate you know
you know whether whether you do any of
these things I just think some of these
are quite specific more specific than
the entirety of society turning on you
and violating the social contract and
biting you to death I think that's quite
scary and I think they presented that in
a new way that would that transcend that
what shot it in a new way but I don't
think the the story itself is Jean rrah
Blair is now this was almost dead right
but I was gonna check out on the fax but
I am telling you the joke I think George
Romero had made one movie near around
that part of the day but I don't think
that that did as well as this I think
this just because this one this one had
I think this one was the new take
ridiculed heavily I mean I remember when
it came out there's a horror fans were
just as upset at this movies they were
like that sort of stuff is is the
criticism of dullards much like the
third act of your boobie I get that it's
a big rule Goldberg machine and I
personally kind of like that but I could
see how people people would be turned
off by one thing I don't like about
horror and I think it's available both
of our both of you guys movies in my
movie you can survive there is a way you
can make it out and it doesn't you don't
have to get a magic reprieve and barely
luck out you can actually survive the
adventure if you're tough enough and
gritty enough to survive society turning
on you whereas in your movie that the
people in that movie are doomed if you
go back through it they're doomed doomed
doomed and it kind of takes some of the
horror out of it for me I see I find out
that they could never have escaped it
becomes a sort of elevated torture porn
to me I think for me even more going
into this movie who don't get it
hereditary and you're like what's gonna
happen what's gonna happen what's gonna
happen and then you realize at the end
of it that that not only could could
they were were they ill-fated but that
they were being manipulated this entire
time they they never stood a chance I
think that makes it even more horrific I
think it's a much more conventional
approach to be like oh you can escape
like like that to me it takes that take
some of the horror the pressure off for
me because oh when you know that there's
some kind of escape than you're just
waiting for that to happen as opposed to
this idea of like it's a hopeless
situation that's the way to agree that
there is no tension if you cannot win
one looks like there's no braver
hereditary starts with them saying like
here's the story of a doomed family
reality dawn on I get that but when you
do get to the end you realize they could
never survive
whereas when you look at when you look
at my film there's so many times that
person could have died I'm a drop of
blood and your eye in your zombie
whether you're a Raider or whatever they
call them in the movies I just I just
think it's overall scarier more
relatable
so guys I'm hearing a lot of personal
preference for better or worse and a lot
of you are making convincing cases for
why you enjoyed that movie the most what
I want to hear in your final arguments
and I guess we'll start with the Greg is
what sets it apart what is unique about
this film sure the other 21st century
horror films well I think with like the
kind of art house horror that we're
getting with films like hereditary and I
kind of feel like 28 days later can be
sort of lumped in that category to is
you sort of get this with this like drug
one dreadful tone throughout and a lot
of them are slowly hereditary especially
as a slow burn and I don't feel like
movies like hereditary it has a low
audience score for a reason it's because
it's just not something that is
attainable for the masses what talking
about best movie I don't wanna just talk
about movies that are only appealing to
cinephiles to the junkies of the screen
or something like that no I don't want
to just talk about those the the film
buffs it has to be a movie that can be
universally appealing I'm like
hereditary is not a film I'm gonna be
like hey babe you want to go watch
hereditary right now or I'm with a group
of friends on their Halloween let's put
on hereditary that's gonna be like it's
slow it's suit it's a slow burn and
honestly at times they catch rags it's
kind of boring and it takes a while for
thrills to kick in and 28 days later the
exciting stuff is all in the first half
in the last half gets kind of lost on
what it's trying to do doesn't even
really feel like a zombie movie at that
point and like we've talked about that
it's like you've pretty much described
to the zombie genre but nothing will
really makes 28 days lism days later
super unique with my movie you
getting a wide variety of tones that are
also under the aesthetic of being
something that's frightening and maybe
you weren't exactly terrified by it
I think most critics and a lot of
audience members were definitely
terrified while watching that film and
to have a pulse to it where everything
about that movie is so meticulously
calculated its specifically edited the
mixture of sound designs in it for every
single frame of that movie the ability
to really maneuver your angles in order
to enhance the narrative of the
characters emotional experience is
brilliant and I think too that she is a
very relatable character we've all made
mistakes and we evolved it felt like
unjustly punished for our mistakes and
that's the ride that she's going on here
and my film also has like an actual
defining villain that is just
breathtakingly scary that whole scene in
the parking lot where she's trying to
kill it to have a how many horror movies
can you say you start laughing and you
start streaming you start laughing and
you start screaming you can't say that
with a lot of movies unless you do it at
the same time Spencer getting closer as
far as like the effects go with the film
- that's meant to be intentional to
release that tension to have like she
pops out you're terrified and in the
effects show and it's kind of goofy well
that's the whole point of it and I also
think my movie for a horror movie
has the scariest ending of them all
hereditary a lot of people were like I
don't know what that's about or people
are like too much of an exposition dump
28 days later sure has like a hopeful
ending note my ending when you have like
this wonderful performance like Justin
Long a very sincere performance when he
this dude who's been doubting his
girlfriend's beliefs the entire time
watch as his girlfriend literally being
dragged to hell and then it's just a
shot on his face and he's got a tear
going down he looks at the button cuz
there is that there is that element that
she had a chance to actually survive
this Edie but she just put the wrong
thing down in the grave when you see
that shot on his face that leaves you
honey you smashed to drag me to hell the
title and you're I remember being in the
videos everyone like oh that is it's
it's the most frightening ending out of
all these three all right ed
well I think it's very easy to look back
on 28 days later right now because it
changed the game so hard and go oh it
was always there it's like saying that
Batman 1989 was always going to be a
success no it was not the guy who had
the right to that had him in his pocket
for twenty years and there was no takers
it was the coldest damn thing ever and
that's what the zombie genre was
ironically enough it was dead and then
this movie comes back and adds an
element of it isn't about dead
shuffling bombs anymore it is about
mankind turning on you with all the
lividity and and and speed that it can
and that is more scary than shambling
zombies you can shuffle away from or
pretend you're one of them and sort of
put some put some clothes you know put
some some flesh on you and stink
yourself up and walk amongst them these
guys aren't falling for the head jazz
dude and that was revolutionary at the
time and it is is the most game-changing
of these movies it isn't a simply a
haunted store a haunted house story it
isn't it isn't big but scarier it's a
real deccan you need to understand the
rules of his drama to deconstruct it and
you need to know the inner workings of
something to bring it back to life and
Alex Garland and Danny Boyle brought the
zombie genre back to life with this with
this movie and I think that's important
and I think as far as a well-made film
it is the most distinctive looking of
these with Sam Raimi me on one side and
Ari aster a new young genius on on each
side I think this movie still the most
visually distinctive that goes towards
being towards being good and towards
being groundbreaking I think all of
these things provide with great central
performances by people who didn't even
seem to be acting because the immediacy
in which it was shot
I think this vaults this over something
that frankly is granted I think Dan's
movie might be a lauded curiosity and I
know that I know that that's as a crowd
pleaser amongst the unpredictable you
know yell at screen crowd but I really
think this movie's gonna last a test of
time alright 20 days later dan why your
film is the best to beat 21st century
it's what you that's what you said
what sets it apart and I think with 28
days later you can certainly debate it's
a great film in the zombie genre I think
with a drag me to hell it's a great film
in the Sam Raimi filmography or in the
ghost genre I think what sets hereditary
apart is the number one it's not easily
categorized you can't really put it into
a box it is it's it is its own it's its
own it's like David has pumpkins it's
its own thing they're ready to jump out
at you if you want to talking about
relatability which is a Greg brought up
with his relatable characters again I
think that it plays on so many different
levels that you are gonna find somewhere
to relate on in whether you're somewhat
afraid of losing a parent with a sibling
a child whether you're afraid of ghosts
whether you're afraid of I mean there is
the concept of a the people that you
know them of turning on you is present
in this film this is scary villain I
think that the scariest villain is in my
movie because it's the person who comes
to you with open arms and says I'm a
friend and they end up being the person
that sells you down the river and seals
your fate and your family's fate that's
the scariest villain to me is the one
that you don't know as a villain that
isn't a crazy lady who give you a hex
and then threw of blood in your mouth
like yeah of course that's the villain I
like the villain that's hiding behind
the smile I think that's the scary of
all you want to talk about craft editing
sound design I will put the
cinematography the editing the sound
design of hereditary up against any of
the technical things I I don't think
that 28 days later has the most
distinctive visual style it was shot on
DV that is a distinct visual style but
the way that the composition of the
shots the lighting of the way that they
do things like the portion at the
beginning of this of my film into the
house into the doll's house and you
realize that this is a family it sets
the stage for this movie so I will put
the Technic the tape the artisanship of
this movie the technicians that put this
movie together against either one of
these two movies any day and then really
the thing that I want to fight back
against the most is this idea that it
cannot be a great movie unless it has
universal appeal I think that is 100%
false some of the greatest movies of all
time don't have what you would call
universal appeal vertigo is not a movie
that is going to appeal
everybody universally it's also not the
kind of movie that you just hey babe
let's throw on vertigo and watch it that
doesn't mean it's not a great film it's
just the different films serve different
functions so I don't think you should
ding hereditary because some audiences
didn't like it or because it doesn't
have universal appeal I think that's the
sign of a challenging film I think
that's the sign of a film that's not
just a crowd-pleaser or the new entry in
a genre that's already popular that may
have helped to reinvigorate it that is
the sign of a film that is singularly
connects with an audience and maybe that
can be a negative connection but that
means that it stands apart it's not just
another piece of a predictable genre it
is its own it stands by itself and I
think the hereditary over time will come
to be regarded as one of the great films
of the early 21st century and I think in
the horror genre is going to stand above
both of these all right that's time poof
Dan's good at this game everyone's good
at this game
excellent excellent work all around
let's let's go to the couch in fact a
lot of people want me to point out
technically in 28 days later they're not
zombies they're still alive
they're called infected they have a
virus so a lot of debate about is it
technically zombies er this is a monster
movie where we're fighting the infected
we do say Romani people instead of the G
word just put that out there that
actresses name is Lorna raver she's been
featured in many TV shows as well as the
old Romani woman from for a bug she's
actually an arrogant isn't crazy okay no
I'm just saying she's actually American
pepper I saw her interviews I was like
whoa Wow
and then we had some sometimes
discussions about these zombie slash
infected timeline 28 days later was 2002
George Romero returned to the zombie
genre in 2005 with land of the dead and
then he did diary of the dead in 2007
and survival of the dead in 2009 alright
on fact there are some effects then has
this work who judges first one moment
you start all great arguments
movies that I probably would not have
picked but I enjoyed hearing everybody's
sort of reasoning for them thank you
yeah we're all hipsters just like Dan
kind of made this point a really great
kind of kind of lost it a little for me
at the end focusing a little too much of
mainstream appeal which especially my
horror genre I just feel like it's too
hard to tell it's very subjective I
don't know if I would have gone like
that so I really came down to ad versus
Dan for me and I really liked a lot of
what I had to say about 28 days later
and its impact on the genre and how it
sort of revitalized as far as designer a
lot of what we love about zombie movies
today sort of came down through 28 days
later I really that resonated with me so
I'm gonna head okay Wow I thought that
this was not going to be the case but
I'm going with I do think I don't feel
like we heard the most out of you but I
do think that you really set yourself
apart as for what it sets it apart
within the context of the 21st century
and then you really undercut your
argument at the end there when you said
that you can't put a hereditary into a
box it's a question about the best
horror film and to me horror is a genre
with pretty distinct rules and to argue
about why it transcends or isn't or
could be horror couldn't have any hard
genron death like a type of horror film
but that's okay that's a Miss that's we
only go forward here and and Greg I just
think that they ganged up on you a lot
of the head jerk
it was universally appealing made it the
best film like no there's plenty of
popular films they come out all the time
in that genre so I guess we can that's
what the fans wanted but once again just
this one I'll say this was literally
like neck-and-neck and kept changing if
I if we did this in 30 seconds it would
be different but the fans did have 42%
for hereditary 20 percent for 28 days
later 16 percent for dragging me to hell
we got a lot of mentions for the new
Suspiria The Exorcism of Emily Rose all
the conjuring conjuring verse 9 and I
think I've discovered I pronounce horror
wrong just after hearing everyone say it
that's it we could do this all day let's
move on to question number three which
is Bing Bing the new film yesterday is
all about a guy who winks up in a world
where the Beatles never existed my
parents just died what's the best movie
about a real musician or band
I believe we're starting with you Dan
yes I picked one of my favorite movies
Amadeus about Mozart and the conflict
between Mozart and Salieri not only a
great movie but what I mean a great
movie on its own terms but I also love
what it has to say about not just
musicians but artists and how you can be
a great artist and if you just happen to
be born in the wrong time that talent is
not always enough or even though you can
be extremely talented if there's
somebody else out there that's more
talented than you are then you may just
have the bad circumstance of the times
that you live in I love how it gets into
the conflict between gene what is genius
and what is talent what is what what
when a success is deserved and who
deserves it and why I think that's
something when you talk about music and
musicianship and just art these are
themes that artists themselves deal with
all the time and I love that instead of
just being about art and about
music this actually goes into the
conflicts between artists and musicians
and and goes into this like how someone
can be so flawed and yet have such a
singular genius that even though you
were sent the hell out of them and you
have to just sort of respect what they
have and figure out how to live with it
I love the depth and the complexity of
that relationship between Mozart and
Salieri the way they bring in the music
of course Mozart wrote beautiful music I
love how they go into the creation of
that you know not not certainly a modern
musician but one of the most important
musicians of all time
alright great Greg yeah when I think
about this question of like what's the
best movie about a real musician or a
band I think about what I want from that
kind of movie and I I do want to see a
lot of the music really drives and help
drive the narrative and more than just
like oh let's cut to them creating a
song but really see the the meaning of
what the song meant for them as
individuals or as a group or or why
their music specifically more than oh
they're just a great you know they're
great performers but what what made
their their songs so distinct and unique
and why they connected with people and
of course I do want a good story and I
picked the movie the one that just
connected with me in the most walk the
line I know that walk the line on on
paper but if you look at its outline it
can be a little by the numbers for sure
but it's one of those cases of sure the
outline of it can be a little by the
numbers like Bohemian Rhapsody but they
could have a different execution that
feels a lot more different and distinct
like something like people have been
comparing a lot of like Bohemian
Rhapsody and Rocket Man for a reason one
feels like a vh1 movie and the other one
feels like an actual movie and for me
here what I love is how of an intimate
experience this is for the character of
Johnny Cash I think walking in Phoenix
gives an incredible performance in this
film he embodies him hand-picked
personally by Johnny Cash yeah he
actually learned to play the guitar for
six months he learned the same if you
listen to walking Phoenix and interviews
he has an actual like soft-spoken voice
but he had to really develop his voice
to have a little bit of a deeper and
Robert it's a deeper voice somebody
singing okay but also what I love is it
isn't just like it had one of those
things where it just cuts to him
performing whenever there's a
performance they're doing music it's
driving the narrative it's moving the
narrative forward and they're still and
acting emotional performance while the
songs are actually taking place it's
also a beautiful love story that at
first you're kind of like not really
rooting for because it starts off as an
affair but then as it progresses you
really start to root for them and I
think to take something like that which
challenges an audience but then by the
end you feel so heart warmed and touched
by them getting together I think is is
this beautiful and in I Reese
Witherspoon gives a brilliant
performance in the film she won the
Oscar for it to me this yes it is the
crowd-pleaser I think of the three on
her adds yet but this is the
crowd-pleaser of the three but it also
still has a palpable air of authenticity
that I feel like you get the best of
both worlds here with walk the line
alright and what do you pick all right
well I picked a movie where I really
think the movie transcends the musician
but also informs what you think about
the musician and that is what's love got
to do with it about the life story of a
Tina Turner the great Tina Turner
basically the movie I think the way it
sets itself apart from other movie
biopics is it isn't really about her
music making her significant you know a
lot of these movies are about this music
makes this person valuable watch this
movie look at this beautiful genius make
this music that's not what this movies
about this movies about a person who
happens to be a musician who's going
through some of the worst crap for 30
damn years and and and and doesn't even
understand her own value doesn't
understand what family actually means
what love actually means so that at the
end when she's singing what's love got
to do with it it's a powerful anthem of
throwing off the shackles of what she
thought love was you don't mean and and
in that
way when it dovetails back to the music
it has more of an emotional impact than
any other musical biopic I've ever seen
because the songs are actually punches
that she's throwing at her previous
oppression and I think that that's dandy
it is indeed dandy dan do you think oh I
get the punch well I guess I'll start I
love
everybody's movies here and I'm not
doing the joestars one of my best
friends so I'd love to be compared oh
yeah so I really do really really really
love each of you guys movies Amadeus is
great it's a great very fictionalized
account of a real person who is very
music I know you know who's coming I
think that it's not it's not a knock on
it but by definition I don't know that
the musicality in that story can connect
in the way that I just outlined in mind
the musicality in my movie is like I
stated it's punches against depression
it's a real expression of this person
fighting back against something
I love walk the line and I'd love that
the tortured life that you can live as a
dude like him in the 50s drinking a
whole bunch and cheating on your wife
and watching your baby brother in the
laundry cauldron oh wait that was in Rea
the movie that
it's just like down to the numbers walk
hard I mean walk the line is a very it's
good dude it's good but it's good in the
same way that hotel art is all the pain
all the paint is when the rough proper
places it's a boat it's a guy
it's a barn yeah I get it but I believe
that salieri story of unrequited horror
and my story of a woman using her music
to defeat your guy got kicked in the
stomach by an ostrich and didn't put it
in the movie 20 minutes from a lady that
used to back up I believe that the
cheese I'm not gonna try to bring up the
whole universal appeal thing I mean it
is like almost a three hour movie
that people can't connect to it I don't
understand that I also my she like when
I watch Amadeus I'm not even watching
them exactly a movie about Amadeus like
FZ but on the day since Salieri
it's merciless watch that movie too I
don't even really like I know our movies
are not accurate at the same time though
when I watched that movie I'm like nah
that's just not the whole performance of
how Amedeo what's that actor's name who
plays a Thomas yeah I just loves it as
far as I thought the whole like kind of
farting show personality that he has
about him I just did not buy it at all
it was I thought it was kind of an
annoying performance and I don't really
feel like it when I watch this a movie
like this about musician or band I want
to see something that does really
highlight a lot of the what makes the
music so special and I feel like you do
get a different kind of tail here and it
is a great movie at the same time I
don't really get that extra element of
that what I would really want from that
kind of film I first of all I have a big
problem with your music your movie about
the music which is it they change the
music with Conte I don't I don't like
that Joaquin Phoenix sing the songs
Johnny Cash it's such a distinctive
voice that's always been a barrier for
me is that they change the music in the
movie about the music I I understand
that might just be but that was a big
barrier for me I get pulled out when I
see that like what's love got to do it
they would Angela I think Angela baska
is an amazing performance whenever she's
singing I'm like that's a great lip
singing performance but that's I I get
really pulled out knowing that it was so
aware of watching she didn't do a school
play version of Tina Turner's vocals
downloading and buying those versions
that walking fast
is the most popular restaurant first
time here about like walking Phoenix not
and join them I agree with you that the
only not honestly dance movie is pretty
damn good it's long it's arduous but
it's worth it's not it's a little bit
and that performance I agree with you
the performance is a little grating over
that amount of time but what I would say
is what it is to me lacking the only
thing it's actually lacking is it is
more about Amadeus is genius than Sally
Aries life and it's about more it's
about both of those things more than the
actual music it's about the music and
home boys it's like it's like a songbook
it's a sound equipped with like
screenplay parts the affairs talking
about the movie about real musician or
band I the most powerful music scene out
of all of our movies when I mean it's
parody great and walk hard but the
reason why I want card shows parody
because if we talked about this earlier
I feel like it's an iconic scene in
biopic movies and when he what he's
doing like the gospel singing thing and
then he's told exactly like we've heard
this kind of tune a billion times before
give us something different that
immediate moment actually changed my
whole perspective on how I view music I
did I found that I wanted a search for
meaning in it like my dad listen to
Johnny Cash I wasn't a Johnny Cash fan
there's no biopic I've seen that
actually made me go out and go wow I
have a whole new appreciation for the
lyrics of Johnny Cash and that movie
really contributed that element me up my
friends and I who all saw together we
all sort of like buying Johnny Cash
albums because of that but I think
that's the downfall of both of your
movies which is that both of these
movies are great if you're a fan of
Johnny Cash 14 the time wasn't you an
alert but bore you learn more and now
you're more into Johnny Cash 14 attorney
but it still tied so much to just
specifically these two people whereas I
think that Mozart and Salieri first of
all I disagree completely that it's not
about the music the entire combination
of the film is that scene where Mozart
is on his deathbed dying writing that
last thing in Salyers like I think I
can't keep it makes it it makes the art
of music composition like a cliffhanger
scene I'm just like trying to get the
notes down but tried to get them out and
you can hear the music
it brings you to the mind of a composer
as he's writing music in a way that no
other movie has done before and I don't
think you have to be just a fan of
Mozart to appreciate the movie because
it is about both boats Art's genius and
Salieri struggling to live it my only
rebuttal to the point that you just made
specifically is that you have to be or
it's beneficial to be a Johnny Cash or a
Tina Turner fan before you watch these
movies and they I say I became a fan of
Tina Turner watching what she went
through I wasn't in like a kid in the
eighties jamming out to frickin Mad Max
soundtrack or nothing but I liked I
liked what her music represented after I
saw her life and to me that is great
trademark of a music a musical biopic is
that after it you're it's like you know
when you watch one of these some of
these great band documentaries you're
one of those to the music afterwards the
great biopic is even more effective at
introducing a new music than that
because it has the emotional element and
I think that is frankly very very very
present in mine
somewhat president is and less president
yours I do agree with you though that's
a very beautiful scene at the end it's a
beautiful beautiful scene about math but
I think we're presenting things about
about music at this point but it's
literally about writing music of
actually going inside this guy's brain
as he's attempting to write that you're
brought into this genius it is 100%
about the music it's an analytical
approach but it's not an emotional time
good great round guys great round final
thoughts oh no I feel like the thoughts
were were relatively finalized they're
actualize us theatrical cut is 161
minutes long 2 hours and 41 pretty close
to three days the film has been
criticized for being historically
accurate but not the poop and fart jokes
mozart jokes about
the guy who wrote the play that Amadeus
is based on like why would you include
all that crude stuff about this
brilliant composer he's like because
it's actually true it's awesome okay
well I guess I'll start off man Greg
that Hotel art oh then walk the line is
the hotel art of music biopics that's
that's just killer no they kill me with
that that it is like ray that it is like
walk hard to kind of by the numbers of
it by your own admission kind of sunk it
for me off the boat off the bat it was
down to Ed and Dan and it's really just
a matter of preference of whether that
music was whether the move was
transcendent to make a point about this
person's life or the movie was
transcendent to say something maybe
about music in general and Dan I think
he put it so beautifully tying it in to
the theme of the film and what it was
able to evoke while still being about
the characters I'm leanin Dan on this
one long Danielle you want to do it
according to the polls right now with
40% it is Amadeus with 30% we've got
walked the line with 28% we've got what
loves got to do with it rock me all
right they're going down I was gonna go
with them as well I really liked as
argue it about how the the music and the
themes of the movie kind of come
together I thought they really did Greg
a lot on the sort of great American
songs look like yeah we all like those
songs but it's kind of just a nice movie
that's full of a lot of good songs but
as I type the whole thing together like
picture of why holidays is such a great
movie holistically that was the question
so I would go through a great game
thanks for playing
I'm glad you voted for me that one time
yes pick your favorites I sure have
experiment surefire way to lose but now
it's down to Dan and Ed in the speed
round and everybody's game just a
one-point difference oh my god
first to four is gonna win the rules
apply as before as always whoever
answers first gets twenty seconds the
next person gets twenty seconds then ten
second rebuttal ten second rebuttal
between me lawn and Daniele herself not
the people will determine so long you'll
be keeping time for me I got it all
right time begins when you answer and
the first question is hmm Paul Rudd has
joined the cast of the sequel
Ghostbusters 2020 Colin I didn't know
that what is the better Paul Rudd
performance Scott Lang an ant-man or
Brian Fantana in anchorman a man Brian
Fantana I'm picking Ant Man because he
has to carry a movie he has to carry a
movie he also has to be a defferent to
other superheroes he has to set up a
whole new way of being super and
introduced that to everybody he's super
charming he has a wonderful daughter the
rapport is there from beginning we feel
him as an estranged father we feel him
as an ex-con it's a really nuanced
performance whereas I do believe Fantana
is a little OneNote his I think it's
easy to stand out when you're the lead
of the movie and it's your job to carry
the movie I think it's harder to stand
out when you're surrounded by other
people who are as good or better than
you at comedy and the fact that we still
remember Brian Fantana and sex panther
and all that stuff is a testament to how
good his performances he holds his own
with everyone else who's also trying to
steal the movie simultaneously it's not
just him playing the hero
it's him carving and
shouts I would argue that it's easier to
lay down salvos of beautiful comedy when
you're a directed missile aimed at one
perfect target its amount of minutes and
I also think that he is better anchorman
relied on him coming up also improving
that's a great thing to do with the
performance I think that helps him not
only did he come up with great some of
the character stuff on the spot that was
because everything else oh good stuff
hmm well and I won't hold that really
dumb point against you guys I think
otherwise your point about him carrying
the movie and his charm and your
rebuttal to Dan about how it's easier to
maybe pick your spots as part of an
ensemble I'm leaning towards you for
that round blonde I actually went the
other way I really like that play it's
harder to stand out when you're started
by Will Ferrell trying to be funny Vince
Vaughn trying to be funny all these
other guys in back in that crazy
ensemble I was gonna go with Dan on this
one okay
Danielle break your tie all right so
just III am gonna hold that against him
because not just not cuz it's a dumb
point but because it's like any time
someone gives up at the end of the round
categorized as a brain just a more
strongly alright well that brings us to
game point for question number two Henry
Cavill will play Sherlock Holmes is
gonna play his little sister he's gonna
play her older brother Sherlock Holmes
you see her on the set of a hatch the
question however is who should play
Henry cavils dr. Watson Ben Affleck Bill
Hader okay I think that Ben Affleck
first of all is very good at sitting
dejected next to Henry Cavill but stop
dr. Watson is next to Sherlock Holmes
all the time in addition I just think
that that would be a very interesting
duo to bring those two together in a
different context and I think that you
need that sort of smaller grounded thing
to let Henry Cavill kind of flex himself
as Holmes I think you need a big
personality I think Watson needs to be
somebody that is basically Sherlock
Holmes not a bodyguard but certainly his
man that gets into fisticuffs with him
he has to be able to do that which Bill
Hader can do is shown that in Barry you
also need an intuitive actor who's very
good at listening and listening with
their face and their eyes which is a
great thing that hater does during all
of a Sherlock saw monologues looking at
haters face as he processes the
information or disagrees
I feel like haters too big of a
personality - he's gonna be trying to
steal the movie along with Henry Cavill
you need somebody who can be his scene
partner but let cavil have the stage I
want to see Bill Hader to his own crazy
wacky take on showhomes Bill Hader comes
from a tradition of collaborative
theater live even so
I do believe he could handle be playing
his part in a movie of this magnitude
and I do believe he could rein it in
because he is great actor okay some hot
stuff there so why don't we start with
with the chairs long who do you got oh I
really like talk more about the
character of Watson as opposed to a
person we'd like to see with Henry
Cavill again some go ahead Danielle I
have to agree for that exact same reason
I felt like Ed was really about what he
would bring to the character and not
about specifically like that pairing and
I liked that better awesome all right
well I said that really cuz I love that
joke about Ben Affleck as a person who
gets killed for going for the [ __ ]
[Music]
we're learning so much today and in fact
against the wall question number three
spider-man far from home hits theaters
next week what's the better movie
Sam Raimi spider-man 3 or the amazing
spider-man 2 9 3 who spoke first did you
say to a SM I'll go that and you go to
flawed films but actually write
spider-man 3 recently and I was struck
by how good the first half of this movie
is Thomas Haden Church as Sandman has a
great motivation you'd have that
wonderful scene where Peter talks to
Aunt May and she talks about how Ben
proposed to her you haven't that's the
best Aunt May Peter scene in the entire
trilogy yes once you get to venom it
gets a little messy but amazing
spider-man 2 is messy threw out that
thing is worse how worse I do believe
that maybe spider-man 2 well absolutely
flawed and horrible has wonderful gaffes
in it like when a electrogas jumped in
with the electric eels but they're
actually moray eels who are not electric
they're just more scary looking real
stupid stuff like that we are called
Giamatti and a big Rhino suit somebody
get smacked with them
good things in spider-man 3 we talk
about the bad things but there's some
really strong elements not movie you
assume I agree that there are good
things some people laugh and act like
there were some good things that we're
not there's a between ever heard of
killing we got a bunch of dumb stuff
[Laughter]
like the whole thing anoint the King I
love them too yeah then
whose next week in round one it's not
this way I said I thought I might go to
and to throughout this gun wins I to go
through these last four shows unscathed
I'm perfectly fine with whatever happens
next week it's just its icing on the
cake
well there you go isn't it you against
like 15 other people yes some way to
make you lose even if you have to fight
we're all on a trip text can come in at
the end with a speed round and just take
the belt right away yeah that's just how
life works sometimes yes it is and thank
you guys for watching let's do some one
last time where can people find you
online Greg is the most fun of the
rejects yeah never have fun you can hit
me up at www.supermuscular.com of my
podcast nerd goat podcast podcast calm
awesome I'm here I'll be here next week
for last fighter standing hashtag long
movies can be good too
the truth
it was better pull the curtain back too
much mom you're here I'm here hello
Nessen I just like to say everybody
chatroom spinal tap is not a real band
was based I thought about sex but I've
been making the case that there's a
wines based on the real band even those
spinal yes I didn't get to talk to you
guys more about topsy-turvy cuz that is
my favorite because I am a theater nerd
yeah well just find me on twitter at
daniel Radford that's it people thought
was everything serious